the title of today's webinar
is advanced 3d cell models to cancer
biology
using real-time lifestyle analysis
and in this webinar i hope to
demonstrate how this approach
of lifestyle monitoring and real-time
quantification
can provide further biological awareness
which may be missed
possibly with more traditional endpoint
approaches
i will briefly describe validated
protocols for creating
two types of 3d multicellular tumor
steroid models
and how biological parameters such as
the growth and viability
can be returned through the capture and
analysis
of bright field images using integrated
software designed specifically for 3d
cultures
and finally demonstrate how the
development of more complex co-culture
models
can be investigated using the incusi s3
i think you would agree there's a name
for increasing drive
to improve the rate of success of
anti-cancer treatments
transitioning to the clinic an accepted
or very much acknowledged way to achieve
this
is to more closely align in
vitrocellular models
with each stage of pre-clinical animal
and patient models the example on the
right hand side of this graph
describes some ways to achieve that
so for example better access and used to
patient specific material
can help as well as better understanding
of heterogeneity
and the importance of the tumor
microenvironment
in addition advances in gene
manipulation techniques
as well as improve techniques for tissue
renewal can aid further
incorporating 3d models is very much
accepted if not mandated
in achieving more physiologically
relevant in vitro cancer models
here i want to spend a little time
briefly describing
two 3d models of multicellular tumor
spheroids
and perhaps why you would choose one
over the other
firstly methods that produce uniform
and very much size controlled 3d
steroids
such as single steroids allow you not
only to recreate
the spatial distribution or rather zonal
regions
of proliferating quiescent and necrotic
cells
which are very much characteristic of
solid tumors
but also the physiochemical environment
with respect to nutrient waste
oxygen and nutrient gradients
this exquisite standardization of size
and the formation of a single spheroid
in each well
of a microtiter plate makes this
approach
very compatible with industrial cancer
drug discovery programs
and achieving very strict
high-throughput screening performance
metrics
conversely the lack of standard size and
morphology
is very much characteristic of
multi-tumor steroid models
here steroids are much smaller
they form and grow by natural
aggregation
on or in an extracellular matrix
that closely mimics the tumor micro
environment
this model lends itself very nicely to
capturing and monitoring biology
that arises from naturally occurring
heterogeneous spheroids
and is well suited to use with organoids
and patient-specific material
now you may be well maybe very familiar
with the several published approaches to
generating single steroids
but here i will just focus on the
formation of single spheroids
in ula round bottom plates the schematic
shown here
describes a validated protocol for the
formation
and treatment of single steroids in not
only
96 well plates but 384 well plates
again there are several ways to create
multi-spheroids
using ecms this schematic describes a
workflow
for creating and monitoring
multi-steroids
which have been created on a base of
nature gel
in 9612 flat bottom plates
although not shown here we also describe
a protocol for tumor multi-spheroids
created within a sandwich if you will of
nature gel
that is to say cells are seeded on a
layer of nature gel
followed by an additional layer of
matrigel which is added on top
both of these protocols described have
been validated for use on the inkysite
s3
and coupled with new integrated software
specifically designed for these 3d
culture models
allows for the continuous lifetime
monitoring and quantification
of biological parameters such as steroid
morphology
growth and viability
but here are some videos of single and
multi-tumor steroids
creating the protocols i've just
described
you can see that the inky site captures
both high density
phase contrast so a high definition
phase contrast as well as bright field
some of you may already be very familiar
with the challenges of consistently
segmenting or masking phase objects
in particular phase images are very
large
single spheroids of greater than 500
microns in diameter
where the center of the spheroid will
often appear out of focus
and equally poor phase contrast images
of multi-spheroids
that sit on the meniscus of an
extracellular gel
we use a proprietary method to capture
both
to capture depth of focus bright field
images
from both of these models note how the
inky site
is able to consistently mask these
brightfield images over time
as shown by the yellow outline mask on
the bright field images
so this slide illustrates how the size
or rather the area of a population of
multi-spheroids
can be tracked and quantified over time
using a label-free approach
that is using the brightfield images
displayed here
you can see that the s3 is able to
achieve this for multi-steroids
which have distinctly different
morphologies so on the top panel
this is illustrated with the round
morphology characteristic of
mcs7 steroids and on the bottom panel
a more branched or stellate morphology
of the mda cells
which is characteristic of an invasive
phenotype
the graphs on the right hand side show
the different temporal profiles
of the two cell types tracking not only
the growth
but the lack of growth or death induced
by the treatment of a known cytotoxic
agent camtasium
i just want to introduce you to a new
feature that's specific to the s3
and not available on previous versions
of the inky site
this is the deep view you can see
it's a simultaneous visualization of all
images
in each well of your microtiter plate
enabling very rapid identification and
assessment of wealth
there's a zoom in function that allows
you to interrogate
a region of interest and the visual is
continually refreshed
as you scroll through time here you can
see
a matrix set up assessing the growth and
shrinkage
of four tumor cells multi spheroids at
two densities
here are the phase images from all 96
wells
the bright field images as well as the
bright field overlay mask
for each object within the well
quantification of those images in the
form
of a plate view showing multi-sphere
growth across all treatment groups over
a 10-day period
can be readily visualized again
this plate view is updated in real time
where images are automatically analyzed
as soon as they are captured
so returning to how assessment of images
and videos through time
can provide additional biological
insight
here is some validation data showing how
the size
of a549 multi-spheroids is dependent on
cell seeding density
so hopefully you can see on the left
panel
cell seeded at the higher density
achieve a growth plateau
sooner than cell seeded at the lower
density of one thousand cells per wealth
something you may well predict and
reasonably speculate
is due to a depletion of nutrients over
the 10 days in culture
the middle plot quantifies the number of
multi-spheroids that form
for each seeding density and how that
changes over time
interestingly this decreases for the
highest seeding density
the dark blue line four thousand cells
per well
but remains i would say relatively
constant for the lowest ceiling density
closer inspection of the videos and
images from this experiment
show that this is due to neighbouring
multi spheroids
merging to form a single larger spheroid
finally looking at the average size
metric so that's the panel on the right
hand side
you can see that cell seeded all three
densities
have the same growth rates over the
first 72 hours
post formation and cells seeded at the
higher density
have the smallest average size
and i guess since they are further apart
from each other the lower density
multispheroids
are less likely to merge and have more
room to continue to grow
to a larger average size
i think you'd agree that this type of
matrix or validation
experiment described with these
associated metrics
allows you to easily define final assay
concentrations accordingly
for example knowing what seeding density
to use
if you wanted to minimize the
impact of merging in your experiment
so earlier i showed you how bright field
image capture
from control wells and treated wells
with a known cytotoxic agent
could be used to quantify growth and
death of multi-steroids
now one might argue that this is not
actually death but possibly the lack of
growth we are tracking in treated wealth
and a way to verify this would be to use
a cell health reagent
such as inky site cytotox green
this is a non-perturbing dye to normal
cells which has a very low intrinsic
background fluorescence
and only becomes fluorescent upon
binding to dna in unhealthy cells
the bright field videos on the top panel
show the control spheroid continues to
grow
while the treated steroid does not and
this can be quantified and displayed in
the top
right hand plot tracking spheroid area
the fluorescence videos on the lower
panel show firstly
a strong fluorescent signal in the
treated
much smaller spheroid and secondly
a much dimmer signal in the larger
control steroid
and this fluorescence is revealed much
later compared to the dying well
quantification of this cytotoxic mode of
death can now be determined
without the need to perform fluorescent
object masking
which can be very subjective and the
interpretation of results
often influenced by thresholds the user
might set for flesh
for fluorescent segmentation
now a new metric within the s3 specific
to single spheroids and multisphere
protocols is described and this returns
the intensity of the fluorescent signal
within the bright field boundary
i.e very much with respect to the size
of the steroid
and you can see that this is verified by
looking at the bottom right hand plot
which shows an increase in the intensity
of the green signal
in the treated well
now the use of the inkocyte cell health
reagents
can be extended for use with
multi-spheroids
here we have an example of mda
mb231 multi-spheroids treated with
camtasia
just like the previous example and as
with single spheroids
quantification of bright field images in
the top panel
illustrates the continued growth in the
control well
so that's in blue and a lack or
minimal growth in grey of the treated
multi-spheroid
the use of a five here in this example
and the quantification of the green
fluorescence intensity
in these images illustrates apoptotic
death by camtasium
now these dual readouts can be further
multiplexed
with an alternative measure of steroid
growth and viability
so here these cells stably express the
red fluorescent protein
and they're being referred to as mda not
like red cells
you can see the increase in the
intensity of the red fluorescence
signal in the growing spheroids and the
decline observed in the treated steroids
shown in the bottom panel of videos the
corresponding time
course demonstrates how the fluorescent
signal from stably integrated fts
can be used as a potential surrogate for
monitoring growth
and viability
so of course everything i've shown you
for monitoring and quantifying growth of
steroids in a label-free manner
can easily be achieved using
fluorescence as i've just described
here we have another example of a deep
view illustration this time
of mcf7 multi-steroids stably expressing
rfp
and you can see we can rapidly determine
the impact
on the potency of three cytotoxic agents
on multispheric growth and viability
and finally the plate view shows the
quantification of both those bright
field images
and fluorescence intensity signal across
the treatment groups
so here from a single well we're able to
discern
both the label free metrics from the
breitfield images
as well as the fluorescent viability
metrics from the fluorescent signal
the changing tack slightly i think when
i started
i tried to highlight that advanced 3d
spheroid models
are becoming increasingly important and
being accepted as a key tool
to enable better assessment of cancer
and in this instance
cancer immunotherapy here is an example
of three
of a 3d single sphero tumor model
looking at the growth
and immune destruction of a tumor
spheroid
the videos on the left show how the red
fluorescent protein
expressed in these scoff steroids
continues to increase in intensity
through time
as the spheroid grows the middle video
shows that there is minimal death ie
minimal loss of fluorescent signal
occurring in this spheroid
upon inclusion of non-activated pbmcs
interesting to note how the pbmcs
initially
surround the spheroid but then appear to
retract and continue to
move somewhat randomly around the
spheroid
in stark contrast accepting activated
pbncs
display enhanced and targeted killing of
the spheroid
and this is manifested as a loss in
fluorescent signal
and lack of growth of the spheroid
so all these phases of immune targeted
death that i've just described can be
easily quantified on the incusi
s3 we observe a concentration dependent
inhibition of
steroid growth by herceptin so that's
through
the loss of the fluorescent signal from
the dying spheroid
and we can demonstrate that this is a
specific effect since we don't
see the same observation in her
two negative spheroids a549
we've also gone on to show that how
there is an activator dependence
on tumor steroid cytotoxicity where
kinetics of death
between different subpopulations of
immune cells occurs
so for example we've observed that t
cell mediated death by the activation of
with anti cd3 and il-2 occurs more
rapidly
than nk mediated death with a different
range of activators
but it's also worth reminding ourselves
that this may reflect
potential differences in the
concentrations of
subpopulations of these immune cells in
the pbmc prep
and also take into account potential
donor to donor variations
so again with this increasing drive to
build more translational 3d cancer
models
recapitulating the tumor micro
environment is key to achieving this
so here i wanted to demonstrate how we
could monitor the effects
of stromal cells and in this case normal
human derma fibroblast
on tumor multi-spheroid morphology
so you can see just by focusing on the
videos on the left hand side here
the inclusion of these fibroblasts with
mda multisteroids encourages them to
form a more stellate morphology
very early on in the time course of this
experiment
but as that experiment progresses you
can see that both cultures
take on a very much equivalent
morphology
interestingly it's only in the presence
of fibroblasts
that skbr3 cells form more compact
steroids
so you're now looking at the right hand
panel of videos
and homing in on the bottom one and in
the absence of these fiber bars
i think you'd agree that they remain
very much as loose
aggregates
so here is a quantification of the skvr3
videos that you've just seen on the
previous slide
where the total area metric indeed
aligns with what you've just seen
in that there is the greatest area
coverage with skbr-3s
in the absence of fibroblasts
these two cultures have been treated
with cantothesin that cytotoxic agent i
spoke about earlier
and an area under curve analysis
performed as the whole time course
to show that scamptothesin displays the
same potency
across both treatment groups
taking this one step further and
performing more detailed
compound profiling here we illustrate
differential pharmacology
in this example across four tumor breast
cell lines
so as alluded to earlier the broad
spectrum anti-cancer compound
counterfeiting
as you would probably predict is showing
an equipotency across
all four cell types in contrast
lepitonib which is a dual her1 her2
tyrosine kinase inhibitor
shows marked activity at both skbr3
and bt474 multi-steroids
with marginal inhibition displayed
in the other two cell types in contrast
the progesterone receptor antagonist
zk164015
strongly inhibits the growth of mcf7
multi-steroids
and then followed by skbr-3s and bt474s
interestingly to note the rank order of
potency
of lapitanib and the zk compound align
very nicely with the known expression
profile of the receptors
that these compounds are known to target
now having demonstrated the s3's ability
to acquire and analyze images
from 3d multi-spheroid co-culture models
you may consider using fluorescently
labeled endothelial cells
instead of fibroblasts or possibly
studying the impact of immune cells
and stromal cells on tumor spheroids in
a tri-culture setting
so in summary i hope i've demonstrated
to you
the key features of the new inquisite s3
software
which is as i've said has been designed
specifically for monitoring 3d cultures
giving you a flavor of the integrated
workflows
and the automated lifestyle analysis for
both single
and multi-spheroids and how real-time
image-based approaches enable assessment
of steroid morphology
how steroid growth and viability can be
determined in a label-free manner
and fluorescence way by multiplexing
either with incus cell health reagents
or using stably integrated fluorescent
proteins
and how the complexity of both single
and multi-spheric monocultures can be
increased
through the addition of immune cells or
stromal cells
and the study of their effects can be
performed on the inky site
so if you're interested in any in any
additional information on the areas i've
touched on today
whether that be the software the
protocols or indeed the use of these
cell health reagents described
they can be found by following the links
on this slide